what took so damn long to make this
second movie well we just took a rare
turn we decided to have a good script
before we started shooting how's that no
no I get that I get that I get that it
took a while take a while you have folks
that weren't even born when the first
movie was made so how do you translate
that feel because it was such a big deal
back then no it's a well you know the
the great thing is you don't have to
have seen the first one in order to
appreciate this stands alone and it's
great but it is a sequel and it carries
through a story I don't know this guy
he's stepping in joseline Gosselin take
it ride
what was it like once you finally hit
the set and you know that I mean this is
a very influential science fiction movie
now you're making me nervous I was kind
of in a constant state of this feeling I
was you know it's it really was it's
kind of surreal to be a part of this
film because it's such a you know an
important part of film history and also
you know obviously a great admirer of
Harrisons and so to get to work with him
and you know hang out in these
situations it feels very yeah very lucky
that's Indiana Jones that's Han Solo
that's I mean that's like I had some
movie history I know but he's cooler
than all of those characters too you
know you realize that like all of those
kind of iconic moments from those movies
or things that he wrote or created
Oh